that's Tina Fey that's Tina Fey from
Saturday Night Live hello hello hi Oh
once I'm sorry I thought you were okay
she looked like she looked a lot like to
unify hello hello I thought that was
Tina Fey
hello Pawnee my time in office has come
to an end a lot has been done but I
wasn't really doing very much I wasn't
paying attention most of the time
fortunately the citizens of Pawnee
didn't pay attention either so if
there's credit to take I will humbly
take it and if there is blame it's your
fault thank you and goodbye forever
hello hello what's your name my name
knows can you spell that please M and he
be okay
sickly yes the clay is silent all right
got it you seen this man before he was
shot last night oh thank you you know
sir that's ours
[Applause]
oh here this is my boss Jack Donaghy hi
welcome to New York let's see we're
using credit cards and cabs now all the
galleries have moved to Chelsea and
we're off cupcakes and we're back to
donuts would you excuse me from you know
the baggage handler told me about the
storage unit party that's on the lower
Eastside starts about midnight sponsored
by near vodka and I think some drug
dealer of some kind but the only rule is
that we all have to DJ Sam hi nice to
meet you mrs. Hannah day please call me
Lily let's play bridge you can be my
partner all right Lily
[Music]
hey here's someone who may be able to
convince you
hello mrs. Obama hey grant how you doing
good good this is Leslie Knope she's
considering a job with us running the
new Midwest Bureau in Chicago well you
know how I feel about Chicago you are
from Chicago so you like it that's right
and we need passionate people like you
in our national parks you know they get
hundreds of millions of visitors each
year are you nodding because you agree
with me
yes I do agree with you I agree with you
on all things throughout history until
the end of time forever you and grant
work together yeah we work together a
lot he's helped me integrate the Let's
Move program into our national parks you
know getting kids outside rock climbing
hiking well that's really really
incredible great work I'm sorry I'm
talking so loud I'm getting louder now I
can't stop my apologies just yeah I'll
fade you were just making out with
peralta huh there's that candy bar
wrapper I was looking for Oh
Santiago what are you doing here so I
guess it is hos before Cho's with you
friend now I understand why nothing gets
done in this precinct the detectives are
too busy frenching with each other you
know what your little honeymoon is over
cuz as long as I'm here you two are done
and I'm gonna be here a long long long
long long long long long oh this is a
heart attack this right here this is a
heart attack oh it's a big one he hasn't
left his home in almost three years I
hope he shows up for dinner he's already
here
thank you all for coming tonight because
of my severe agoraphobia and my
debilitating wealth I am forced to bring
the world to me and host dinners for
interesting people from all walks of
life the world of fashion society art
collecting and yelling why isn't there
any good art in here come on business
and historical fiction really what if
the Germans had won the war lemon and
the arts
I'm glad Jack was able to bring you Liz
I asked him about you after I saw your
photo in the Style section of the New
York Times funny story I was only
wearing that because the fire alarm went
off while I was getting a haircut well
you look beautiful and as always I keep
one chair empty to represent our
unfulfilled hopes and dreams I'm just
kidding Eliot Spitzer's hooker couldn't
make it sorry I'm sorry I'm working on
an English character would you mind
it's called Reginald Oh Michael
Scott oh I do characters as well oh my
god I've got a Chinese fella no
philately Craig please called holy noise
sounds like no no no and people don't
understand that it has nothing to do
with making fun of it of a different
nationality
yeah no comedy is a place where the mind
goes to ticularly south that's what she
says I have a staff of creative geniuses
that will not stop working until we win
this bid Leslie I couldn't find that
file you wanted but I did find a file
called bird census 1980 and it's empty
get out of your head I fired you right
if anybody wants to hang I will be a
subway
it might be tea I need a commandeer this
vehicle it's a crossover it's a
crossover SUV and you can't have it I'm
a cop can you please get out of the car
no this is Schmidt's mom's car and I'm
more scared of her than I am of some
two-bit thug I'm not a thug I'm police
okay their name one law don't kill
people that's on me I set the bar too
low look please just get out okay you
can drive I'm not getting out right also
I have a seat one wrong I don't just
have a really hot butt excuse me I'm
supposed to meet you here huh are you
Wesley
I'm Carol I'm sorry what's happening now
I'm supposed to meet a Wesley about my
insurance claim Wesley doesn't work here
anymore are you serious I mean I made
the appointment like a month ago I
rearranged my whole Saturday are you
door man yeah I'm a doorman to the sky
I'm a pilot oh okay
well look it's a pretty standard
workman's comp claim I'm sure you could
handle it I was flying the 7:00 a.m.
from Tampa to Louisville and we had a
two-hour weather delay so naturally all
the passengers got drunk generally
speaking if there's a delay of more than
20 minutes I might as well be driving a
party bus it's just idiocy I don't know
what's going on in this country
I know people wear flip-flops to church
and the NBA tattoo situation is out of
control
thank you anyway we're about a half hour
into the flight I hear this commotion
behind me in the cabin so I exit the
cockpit I go down the aisle and to my
left I see a terrorist no I wish no it's
a drunk lady she's pulled her pants off
and she's ranting she's complaining
about the in-flight entertainment so
things got a little heated and
I had to implement sky law what's the
sky law it's when I put on the fasten
seatbelt sign and no one's allowed to
move til we've had ten minutes of
silence I made the whole thing up but
you know people are stupid so they don't
question it that is awesome
so what does the workman's comp part of
this eventually I flipped the drunk lady
off she bit my finger I know I was
totally unprofessional but she was
bagging pretty hard on my TGS what TGS
it's this late-night show on NBC we run
it in flight when we're northwest bound
basically the greatest thing ever on
television I don't stand for anybody
beasts marching it on my aircraft
I want the jab I really do it's just the
rest of my family's in the Finger Lakes
right now I'm supposed to be in the
Finger Lakes right now I told him I was
on a hike snuck away to do this
interview I got to get back pretty soon
don't worry people disappear in the
Finger Lakes
look behind you but don't be obvious
could I get me soft-shell crab Josh
Groban he's eating his own so she
doesn't want baller thing I've ever seen
you know actually heard about a guy who
died while eating hot wings we yeah he
was terminally ill beforehand Oh
unrelated I always thought I'd die at
the hands of my own clone well that's
why you have to brand the number two
into your clones cheek you shouldn't
have a clone if you don't know that all
right you ready here we go that's
nothing
Amateur Night I can't believe this had
three peppers next to it on the menu oh
my god
[Music]
knapsack and I lost my Bakugan Trapper
Keeper Snickers bar thermos hit the
floor broken abside what is that
weird al' yankovic parody your song like
Michael Jackson's eat it or Adele's
someone likes food it's a huge honor
like when people want to see your boobs
at Mardi Gras there's nothing like that
you